hey everybody and welcome to my tutorial
on how to solve a 6x6 cube the cube I
will be using is the V cube 6 which as
of now is the only cube that has been
created with 6 layers as you might
already know solving a 6x6 is very
similar to solving both a four by four
and a five by five cube so I highly
recommend that you know how to solve
both and I do require that you can solve
at least a 3x3 cube you can view my
tutorials for all of those cubes on my
channel playlist by clicking on my name
what I will be teaching in this tutorial
is the reduction method what that
requires is that you solve the 6x6 cube
centrepieces then you pair up the edge
pieces and fix all of the parity errors
and finally solve the 6x6 cube as a 3x3
because the six by six is an even
layered tube we will also encounter
parity errors when solving a cube as a
3x3 I'm going to first explain the new
notation I will be using and also the
component pieces of the 6x6 cube with
this method you should be able to solve
any sized big cube alrightso notation
for the 6x6 cube is a little bit
different since we do have different
types of inside layers for the
algorithms we're going to be turning the
outer layers by themselves two layers
together and also three layers together
an uppercase letter means that we're
going to be turning an outer layer by
itself a lowercase letter means that
we're going to be turning more than one
layer either two layers or three layers
any numbers which are in front of the
lowercase letter lets you know how many
layers to turn so if I have a three
little D it means to turn all three down
layers clockwise a quarter turn a
lowercase L with an apostrophe or prime
symbol after it means we must turn to
left faces counterclockwise a two can be
used in front of the L however it's
usually left out three little u2 would
indicate we must turn the three upper
layers twice
and a big r2 would mean we must turn the
outer right layer twice now that you're
familiar with the new notation let's
take a look at the component pieces of
the 6x6 cue all right so since the 6x6
is an even layered cube there is no
center axis piece that defines exactly
where the center's belong the
centerpieces are arranged as a 4x4 block
there are four inner center pieces per
side there are eight edge Center pieces
per side and there are also four corner
Center pieces per side each set of
Center edge pieces has a left and a
right piece there are also 12 groups of
edges which are composed of four pieces
there are two inner edge pieces and
there are also two outer edge pieces all
cubes also have eight corner pieces now
that you know what I will call the
pieces let's move on to placing the
center's placing the centers on the 6x6
cube is fairly intuitive and very
similar to solving the Centers of both a
four by four and a five by five a five
by five however and all odd tubes have
center axis pieces that are stationary
what that means is that the black center
will always be opposite the yellow
Center the Green Center will always be
opposite the blue Center and the red
will always be opposite the orange
learning the color scheme of the cube
will help you arrange the center's
properly on the 6x6 cube what we're
going to be doing on the 6x6 cube is
creating four of these 1 by 4 blocks and
we're going to be joining them together
to form a 4 by 4 Center understanding
what types of pieces make up both the
outer and the inner blocks is important
for solving the center's inner blocks
are made up of the inner center pieces
and also the edge Center pieces while
the outer blocks are made up of the edge
Center pieces and the corner center
pieces so now let's try to form a center
on a mix up cube all right the first two
centers I'm going to place are the black
and the yellow centers which are always
opposite each other
so looking around the cube you want to
find centerpieces which may already be
in the same layer that way we can
complete a one by four block these two
Center edge pieces are in the same layer
and need to be joined by 2 corner Center
pieces in order to complete this outer 1
by 4 block so we look around the cube
for two corner center pieces here is one
and here is another one this one is in
the upper left of this 4x4 Center block
while this one is in the lower right so
if you look at the empty positions this
one's in the lower right and this one's
in the lower left so that's where we
need to get these pieces this one is
already there in the lower right so we
can flip it into that empty spot this
one is in the upper left so we need to
get it down into the lower left so that
we can flip it into that empty spot so
now we have completed our first 1 by 4
block looking around the cube you want
to find pieces again which may be in the
same layer alright so here we have
pieces that are in the same layer in
order to complete this inner 1 by 4
block we need to get an inner center
piece and a right-center edge piece so
here we have an inner center piece what
we can do is we have a right edge center
piece here next to it if you'll see if
you turn these so that they're on the
same layer as these two this one will go
in this spot and this one can go in this
spot so what we can do is we could turn
this piece up there first now you have
three now looking at the position of
this one it's in the lower right of this
2x2 inter center block and so is this
empty spot so all we have to do is bring
this piece into that spot to do that you
bring three faces and then you bring two
back so now we have another one that we
could join to this one this one is
vertical we need to get this one
vertical so that we could join it to
this one so now we can bring this piece
down to that face alright so now we want
to get another 1 by 4 block so these two
pieces are in the same face here to
finish this 1 by 4 in our Center block
we need to get an inner center piece
and a right edge centerpiece so here we
have an inner centerpiece this empty
spot is in the lower right of this two
by two block so this needs to go to the
lower right now we could flip this piece
into that empty spot so we bring three
and then bring back two now we just need
a right-center edge piece so here is a
right-center edge piece we put it in the
same layer as these three by twisting
this face counterclockwise like that now
it's in the right position for joining
it to these three so we just bring it up
to that face and we have finished our
third one by four block so we want to
get it next to these two so we put this
vertically and now we could flip this up
into that empty position now we just
need one more outer 1 by 4 block so here
we have two pieces and we just need
those two corners again like the first
one we did so if we look around the cube
here are the two corners they're already
next to each other position correctly
all we need to do is get it into the
same layer as these two so we put it
onto the bottom layer and now we can
just flip these two pieces down next to
these two one two and we have finished
our fourth 1 by 4 block so we hold this
this is vertical we just need to get
these two these 3 vertically now we
could flip this into the empty position
and we have finished our first 4x4
Center block all right so now that
you've seen the method for forming 1 by
4 blocks you should have a better
understanding of how to create the
center's I'm going to go a little faster
when explaining the remaining centers we
need to get the yellow Center to be
opposite the black Center so we needed
to go here so we have three pieces up
there what we could do is we could join
this piece up with those so we put it
horizontal and now we have this piece
however when you do that you're going to
mess up the center's so you turn it
vertical and then bring this back
alright so here we have a corner piece
we could put it here and we can get
another corner piece and put it there
now we have another 1 by 4 block put
this vertical flip it up when you do
that you mess up the center's so we flip
it up turn this twice and then put this
back ok so we have two pieces up here we
can get this piece up next to it now we
just need to find a corner piece here's
a corner piece we can flip it all the
way around and now put this vertical
take that end piece out turn the top
twice and then put this back down now we
have three and we just need to get one
more so this piece can go next to this
piece and then we just need two more
here's the other one
whip this around in that empty spot it's
in the bottom right this last piece so
we put the piece in the bottom right
turn three and bring back two now we
have the last one now you can't just put
it in that empty spot by twisting it up
like that that would mess up the black
Center so what you do turn it around and
you kick out this other inner 1 by 4
block 3 and 2 turn the top twice and
then bring that piece down and now we
have the yellow Center complete and
opposite the black so now you're ready
to go on and place the remaining 4
centers